one of our first interviews was in
Boston and Eddie who's who you know runs
the production really had to become very
very quickly up to date on how to set
this whole thing up and he's done an
amazing job the very first time we were
setting up there was one tiny error
which it's bizarre how tiny things can
seem huge when they happen and it was a
missing battery which ended up not
actually measuring at all but I decided
we had this big important business
person coming on Michael Porter and it
was our first interview on location
somewhere and we had very limited time
to set up and he was on his way in and
he was going to give us a specific
amount of time and that was it and so
there was this battery I don't even
remember what it was for maybe the
microphone or something like that and so
we were like what the heck are we going
to do and it was maybe half a mile to
this staple store and because I'd lived
in Cambridge I knew where the store was
so I said I'll go and I was wearing some
kind of boots and it was really really
hot that day and I ran to the store and
there were people like I literally
shoved an old lady out of the wait to
pay it's like threw down twenty dollars
was probably like two dollars and just
took the batteries and ran all the way
back and when I got in there Michael
Porter was there and I was just sweating
disgustingly and then I was also the
makeup artist so I had to do his makeup
and sweat was pouring off me and I don't
even think it was that funny but the one
I remember the most
you